veteran campaigner jimmy lye has been
detained many times
but this was the first time he was taken
away in handcuffs
ly told ew that although he expected his
arrest
he was surprised that it came so soon
and that his sons were also targeted
this time they act so early maybe
because they have to sew the teeth
i was actually shocked and that
makes it more scary especially when
when they take your family involved with
what you do
i think this is a very effective
intimidation
to the community lies says his most
emotional moment this week
was when he was surrounded by supporters
after he was freed on bail
during his 40-hour detention police
showed him interviews he did with
foreign media
op-eds and some social media posts
as evidence of suspected collusion with
foreign forces
a new offense that could put him in jail
for life
i met mike pence i met pompeo and some
of the senators and congressmen in the
u.s
but if that you call this is collusion
what can i say so mostly my collusion
is to have interviews
why are you still doing that right now i
can't be scared if i'm scared i won't be
able to do anything or say anything
that's why i accept your interview
without any doubt
beijing is making similar allegations
against the media tycoons newspaper
apple daily
the most read and critical paper in town
its newsroom was also raided
lie at this message for his staff
i told them that consider your own
safety your conscience
and your obligation to the society we
are not asking you to be the martyr
but you know do whatever you think is
the right thing to do
so we would just continue to do it and
test the water
many protesters have been left wondering
what now as both peaceful and violent
activism
seem in vain the last scale
demonstration will be the thing of the
past
but it doesn't mean that people will
cease to resist
i think the resistance will go on but in
a different way
i definitely don't agree that we have to
confront them head on because this is
going to be a long fight
we have to be flexible and cautious
and creative our only power
is our moral authority why do you
believe that a peaceful protest can
pressure on the chinese government if we
use
violence how can you be more violent
than the
ccp who have guns and tanks
the billionaire fled to hong kong from
mainland china when he was a penniless
12 year old
he attributes his success to the freedom
he found in the territory
but he's not planning another escape
even though he may have to spend the
rest of his life
behind bars i would sing with the ship
because this place gave me everything
you know i i'm in depth to this place
i'm very grateful for what this
what this place has given me i'm 73
almost
so maybe it's a payback time why should
i regret
doing the right thing
and our correspondent phoebe kong who
did that interview with jimmy ly
joins me now from hong kong hello to you
phoebe
so listening to jimmy ly speaking there
he said the resistance in hong kong
will go on but in a different way
what do you think he means by that
well jimin admitted in the interview
that he thinks there's not much people
can do
on the street right now in hong kong
because of the new sweeping
national security law but despite the
fact that like
it's not very possible to help any
massive demonstration but he
think our people should continue to find
other peaceful
and creative ways to sustain the
movement for example
like um the voices support uh like uh to
to other like international communities
because he think
um the uh hong kong uh the the the moral
power is the greatest strength that hong
kongers have at the moment
and that can help them to draw
international support to achieve their
demands
and apart from that he also think that
is also important for the opposition
figures to remain in office like
even though the election is postponed
for more than a year
right now but he thinks it's important
for
people and opposition figures to fight
inside the institution
well phoebe you mentioned jimmy light
talking about support
from overseas specifically support from
the united states
if the u.s is actively supporting hong
kong's pro-democracy
opposition what could that mean for
relations between the u.s and mainland
china
well the u.s china relationship has been
already very intense like through the
past
few months and for the past one to two
years because of the trade war and
because of the hong kong protests
like at broke out last year that we saw
a lot of teeth protect
retaliation between china and u.s and
hong kong is considered
as the forefront of the so-called
neo-cold war between
the two superpowers so we definitely
expect that um
this kind of like intense atmosphere and
the relations will
will um will carry on like because of
the uh
uh the situation now in hong kong that
uh the u.s strongly
opposed to the uh the way of china ruled
hong kong especially the
implementation of the national security
law so
we expect there will be many more like
retaliatory meshes laid up between the
two
superpowers dw's phoebe kong reporting
from hong kong
thank you so much